l'alberta a dépêché nul autre que son
premier ministre en renfort jason kenny
est en mode séduction auprès des
électeurs ontariens particulièrement des
communautés culturelles
il vient donner un coup de main aux
conservateurs d'introduire dans la
grande région de toronto
je crois que les organisateurs voulaient
mettre l'accent sur les comptes est
serré et particulièrement avec les
candidats que je connais personnellement
la tournée du premier ministre albertain
en ontario comprend une vingtaine
d'arrêts dans we lauder d'une
circonscription détenue par les libéraux
il est venu prêter main forte au
candidat local kenny convaincre les
électeurs d'aller voter croise militants
de cette tournée en ontario se déroule
pendant que d'autres fautes demeure
invisible
il est perçu comme une nuisance à
l'image des conservateurs pour plusieurs
le passage de jason kenny dans la
province confirme l'impopularité du
gouvernement ford étant le chef de parti
conservateur de la plus grande province
au canada c'est imparable prétend comme
sur ford alors on dit que monsieur fort
hills est un boulet ont été depuis le
début de la campagne puis ça me semble
être encore le comme ça vient justement
je s'appuyer le cette analyse
j'estime kenny pour sa part n'a pas
voulu commenter l'absence de son
collègue
les autres ministres ont pris les autres
approches politiques que je respecte
chacun à chacune son gain à son goût le
premier ministre de l'ontario n'est pas
l'enjeu de cette élection a tenu à
rappeler le candidat local
il y a quelques mois jason kenny et deux
fois il était vu comme les piliers d'un
nouveau front commun conservateur au
pays
or un peu plus de deux semaines du
scrutin la situation des deux premiers
ministres provinciaux dans cette
campagne offre un contraste frappant ici
mathieu simard radio canada toronto